my name is Neville San Gianna I'm a
biologist at New York University and the
New York genome Center and I've been
challenged today to teach one concept in
five levels of increasing complexity my
topic is CRISPR CRISPR is a new area of
biomedical science that enables gene
editing and it's helping us understand
the genetic basis of many diseases like
autism or cancer I think today everyone
can leave with understanding something
about CRISPR at some level a Tegan do
you know what we're here to talk about
today we are here to talk about science
we're here to talk about something
called CRISPR have you heard of that no
CRISPR is a tool that scientists are
using to edit or change genomes do you
know what a genome is no it's kind of
like an instruction manual the
instruction manual that makes you who
you are
sometimes there's mistakes in the
instruction manual like people get sick
like allergies do you have do you have
friends at school that have allergies
[Music]
that's good that you actually know
exactly what you're allergic to for
people that have really severe allergies
we could erase we're in that in that big
instruction manual where they have those
allergies and maybe make it so that they
don't have those allergies anymore do
you know what CRISPR is absolutely not
CRISPR is a way to edit the genome do
you know what a genome is yeah it's the
DNA DNA is kind of the language that the
genome is written in and the genome
itself is is an instruction manual it
describes how to make you how tall you
should be what color hair you have or
what color eyes you have so what CRISPR
is and an easy way to think about it
it's like a molecular pair of scissors
that can go through that long long
genome and find specific places make
small cuts and edit it what do you think
about being able to edit genomes then
you could change
we changed things about a person if you
edit the DNA sure so how do we determine
what's what's the right uses thing I
don't think you should be used for
almost cosmetology research like for
people just be like oh I want to be five
foot six instead of five foot four or
like reasons that aren't necessarily the
most informed I just think if it could
genuinely help someone like if someone
had cancer and there was a way to fix it
or like slow down the growth so a lot of
the work that we do in my lab is about
being engineers of DNA we try and look
to see what mutations caused diseases
and see if when we change those
mutations if we can take a sick cell or
organism and make it healthy again you
graduate technically cuz the p53 when
it's defect it doesn't that's what
causes cancers p53 is the most common
mutation in cancer that's that's right
yeah that's a great idea actually to use
CRISPR to target tumor cells and restore
p53 to fix that that mutation so to make
that cut with these scissors and fix it
have you heard about CRISPR yes this
revolutionary team editing tool I know
there have been previous gene editing
tools but CRISPR is more revolutionary
in that it's more precise and a little
bit more affordable do you know how
CRISPR works so it works where you have
this CRISPR this caste 9 complex protein
calcium protein caste 9 protein complex
along with something called a guide RNA
that's right that's right and that RNA
will basically tell this protein where
to go and what you need to sort of cut
out right and this is what makes the
CRISPR system very programmable is that
the low piece of guide RNA is easy to
make we can program CRISPR to go to many
different places in the genome quite
easily but I've heard they're like close
to almost curing muscular dystrophy with
it but there's a lot of I guess ethical
issues that come up with it too one of
the really nice things actually about
CRISPR is that we can use it in human
cells no if you ask most people should
you use it to cure cancer most people
would say yeah those those are good good
uses but there are other areas that are
a little bit more problematic like
editing the germline
means something that could be passed off
ethics wise a lot of people have that
natural reaction of fear against
something new because it has a lot of
potential and we just don't know where
it can take us yet it was sort of
similar to like when people started
doing in vitro fertilization test-tube
babies to B that was the kind of scare
totally exactly
but now we see it's perfectly fine as
long you know it's regulated and so
there's been a lot of talk about using
CRISPR for gene editing in humans and
that that can be a controversial thing I
think very naturally there's many
aspects of ethics that need to be looked
at firstly if we're talking about using
CRISPR are we using it in somatic cells
such as t-cells or are we using it in
embryos or germ stem cells and the issue
with that is now you're modifying the
genome at a germline levels any
unintended consequences could go forward
many generations you're saying with
germline is sure there's unintended
consequences but there's also lack of
consent if you are not around you can't
consent exactly so these future
generations or products of CRISPR they
can't consent another I think ethical
component is if CRISPR does make it to
market who will have access to it is
that going to be cost prohibitive we'll
only a certain select few be able to use
it as many new cancer drugs are today
right right will that be how it is yeah
would people start using it for non
therapeutic reasons and I think this
then can get into a whole slippery slope
so I think a lot of people are concerned
maybe that CRISPR will be used in kind
of frivolous ways maybe just to choose
somebody's eye color or or how tall they
are what color hair they have and I
think what a lot of people don't realize
maybe is that the state of genetics is
not quite there it's nice to think that
I can go in and choose exactly what I
color I want but fundamentally science
doesn't exactly know all of that yet
we don't know every single gene related
to eye color nor the regulatory
mechanisms nor the epigenetics this is a
right so so we can use CRISPR now to try
and understand better how do our genes
relate to these these different features
these different phenotypes that that we
have there is a lot of work left to do
before we even know well I think what
are the knobs and dials what are the
controls that you know affect eye color
or how tall you are so I think this
question right now even though it's
important to discuss I kind of feel like
it's more theoretical right now yeah or
is it really even a point necessary for
conversation because people are going
out every single day and getting plastic
surgery to change how they look how is
this any different and in the same slant
people are using in vitro fertilization
right so this is manipulating genomes
you're choosing which embryos to implant
so we're almost doing little aspects of
what CRISPR has the potential to do
so Matt what are you doing right now in
the lab and how are you using gene
editing in your own work right now one
of the questions I've been very much
interested in is trying to understand
the effect of human genetic variation on
using CRISPR casts nine reagents because
you and I just sitting here different
millions of different in locations
within our genome we use these guide
RNAs which are 20 base pairs and we
match it to different places in the
genome but what if there's a mutation at
that site and how does that affect a
mutation that's different between you
and me it's the same site but there's a
slight difference in the DNA between you
and it is exactly let's say in you it's
a perfect match in me there's one that's
actually a mismatch and how does that
affect things in the lab because maybe
it won't be as efficient it won't be
able to bring caste 9 to the correct
site and cut there so when when people
are using CRISPR now in the lab are they
really sequencing the exact cell type
they use sequencing reading out the
genome of that cell before they use
CRISPR not many do that it would
ultimately the best way to do it
for sure because the reference genome
that was published in 2001 was kind of
just one person's genome and as we know
very well from sequencing many different
individuals there are a lot of
differences and so there are some
concerns that when you use these in the
lab that you're intending for a cut to
be made in this one place in the genome
but if there happens to be a mismatch
there because there's some variant in
the cells that you're studying maybe it
won't cut there at all and even maybe
worse is that maybe it'll cut somewhere
else because maybe now it can match
elsewhere so you're saying right now
that it's it's kind of early days with
CRISPR and that there's a lot of
technical issues that really need to be
ironed out that it's not anything can be
targeted at any time we're trying to
develop the scientific steps that will
take us to that kind of total genome
control it is still the early days and
as much progress that's been done which
is actually quite remarkable given how
new this technology is I mean we're just
a few years away from when it was really
started being used for these
applications however having said that I
holds a lot of potential and I think can
get there but there's a lot of issues
and concerns that need to be worked out
I was going to say that a lot of what
inspired me to get into bioengineering
are movies movies like Jurassic Park
which both shows the good
the bad sides of manipulating the nature
around us and so maybe it's a bit of a
silly question but what do you think in
our lifetime will we see something like
Jurassic Park where humans have actually
engineered different different animals
anything is possible
I'm not sure that we will see that in
our lifetimes but I would be very
excited to attend Jurassic Park if that
were the case having said that I do
think that CRISPR Cassadine does have a
lot of potential to two things that are
kind of out of the box in the past few
years we've been able to tackle ideas
that people didn't think we're possible
before that more than anything
CRISPR has created a whole open field of
opportunities and so whether or not that
leads us Jurassic Park I can't tell you
that answer for sure but I certainly
hope that it does and I think you're
right that the opportunities might be
much broader than just biomedical
science it might be things like using
DNA as a hard drive being able to use
CRISPR as a diagnostic instead of just a
tool for editing and we yeah use cells
to record data over time with with
CRISPR can we use CRISPR to track cells
in a developing embryo I think this is
one of the most exciting recent uses of
CRISPR I've seen that I would have never
predicted a year ago the dominant
paradigm right now is CRISPR is just for
cutting DNA but when you think of it
more as a general platform a pointer to
a location in a genome then that becomes
a very very powerful thing do you think
CRISPR will be helpful for understanding
human variation beyond what we already
have just by sequencing people's genomes
yes absolutely I think that the real
power of CRISPR lets us to follow up on
this genetic information that we've been
studying and following for a very long
time now there been a lot of studies
where you take a group of people with
disease X and people without that
disease and you see if any mutations
seem to be preferentially in the group
with the disease and kind of absent in
the group without the disease people
have observed these differences but what
you're saying is the CRISPR we can now
test is this causal this factor if we
make this mutation does it cause the
disease does it either create
sickle-cell anemia or ameliorate sickle
cell anemia and prevent prevent it do
you think we'll ever be at a place where
based on looking at someone's genome and
these kinds of CRISPR functional screens
we can predict
what kinds of diseases these people
might get 10 20 years in the future I
think that's certainly a great goal as
of now we tend to focus on variants or
mutations that we know the function what
about mutations we've never seen before
something that comes from let's say UV
radiation in melanoma or something I
think that we will ultimately have the
power to do that and so thinking about
when you start from mutation do you look
at the expression of RNA is that change
is it changing things at the protein
level so this is interesting so you
mentioned that we can analyze genomes
the DNA level and then you said the RNA
level looking at the expression of genes
and then the proteins the products that
they actually make with proteomics or
mass spectrometry but do you think it's
kind of like another level of
understanding the function of the genome
or do you view it as part of one one of
those those levels I do think it
provides a different level of data the
ability to rapidly and genome-wide
assess and make changes at the DNA level
and then look at the resulting changes
of the RNA and protein level I think is
something that we haven't been able to
do and is now I think on a rapidly
advanced understanding at a genetic
level at the DNA level of a lot of
different diseases so so you and I have
done functional screens we've done these
large-scale CRISPR screens where we
modify many genes thousands of genes or
thousands of locations in the genome all
in kind of a test system but do you ever
see this one day the idea of these
multiplex pooled CRISPR screens going
into the clinic that we actually take a
clinical cell line a cell line from a
patient absolutely I think that is kind
of one of the ultimate goals ultimately
it would be very nice to be able to
correct the mutations for these diseases
we've known about for sometimes hundreds
of years and we just haven't been able
to do anything about there's a lot of
kind of ethical issues surrounding very
reasonably using CRISPR in the clinic I
think there's a lot of concern about
trying to use CRISPR technology other
genome technologies to make humans
designed in a specific way whether you
want to change eye color height or
things like that like kind of irony of
that situation is that the genetics of a
lot of the traits that are you know you
can see by just looking at a person are
quite complex and are not worked out in
the same way so you're saying that the
ethical problem is not really right now
a clear and present issue because for
many of the
perhaps a little bit more superficial
traits that we have we don't really even
know what what genes can control these
these traits so it's probably a good
idea to start thinking a little bit
about engineering somatic cells versus
germline cells which are passed on to
future generations and I think one nice
thing is that most scientists agree that
for at least for human gene editing that
we need to focus on somatic cells which
really impacts a lot of people with
these diseases and that there's many
many issues around editing the germline
where there you're doing something that
might be inherited for for many many
generations so it's kind of an
interesting misconception that people
think that CRISPR is just one thing just
one enzyme casts nine I think that's a
really great point and that speaks to
just how fast the technology is
developing because it started with us
just knowing about cast nine but in just
one cast nine right s pyogenes cast nine
was kind of the first one used for gene
editing in human cells exactly and just
in the past few years this this toolbox
has now been expanded well past that for
example you can look into other
different species of bacteria to find
cast 9 ok so cast 9 is over many
different species it's over a tremendous
amount of bacteria and so you had
reference strep pyogenes cast 9 well if
they you look into Staphylococcus aureus
you can also find cast 9 and that cast
line is just slightly different it can
target different regions of the genome
and so that opens up a whole new set of
possibilities in terms of genome editing
so it increases the targetable space
within the human genome you can target
more regions that you couldn't with that
first first cast line and what I find
actually is a really interesting thing
is that there's this huge meta genomic
diversity of different CRISPR systems
and most of them are really just not
even well characterized yet and I think
the best example that we were talking
about it earlier is this new RNA
targeting CRISPR so instead of cutting
DNA it targets RNA and I think this is
just one example of a complete paradigm
shift I don't think anyone have
necessarily predicted at the beginning
that this would be one of the things
that just was created and existed in
nature and it just took some time for
people to uncover it I think it's a
great good example why it's important
and actually the fund base basic science
because you sometimes when you start out
down a certain path
you never know where you're gonna end up
in the end the more research I can be
done in this area can really unleash new
possibilities finding new things
different versions of cast 9 or other
things that function like cast 9 or
things completely different than at this
moment I can't even think of the
possibilities are endless to be a little
cliche about it now literally I think
they are endless for sure I think it's
great for people of all ages to
understand CRISPR and at least a little
bit about genome engineering because so
much of the world today revolves around
biology also there's something about
self understanding we really want to
understand ourselves and what makes up
ourselves and CRISPR and gene editing is
another way to get at what is the
substance underlying us